so to close today's episode we're going
to be looking at a Reddit story I had my
first experience on pal daily last week
and H read me a Reddit story for which I
was quite shocked by to say the least uh
I have no idea what the team have pulled
together for me today so I'm just going
to read it and we will tackle it
together as it comes so the gentleman
writing this story is 40 years old May
and he is saying that his ex-wife 40
female wants me to be with her in her
last
days okay here's the story I met my ex
when we were both 10 she was is my twin
sister's best friend so we've always
been kind of a trio growing up we
started dating at 14 and got married at
23 things got ugly cuz 5 years after
getting married she told me she had a
monthlong affair with her coworker
apparently the guilt was too much for
her so she confessed we tried to work
through it but after a few months of
trying she knew that despite the fact
that I loved her I couldn't trust her
anymore she told me she still loved me
and that she'd wait for me and prove
that I was the only one I wanted to
believe her but you know some things
just can't be fixed we never had Kids 3
years after the divorce I met my now
wife 38 female We Got Married 2 years
after dating she's everything I could
ever dream of in a wife and more my ex
as my sister told me they're still
besties never really recovered she quit
her job and is now working in a
church throughout my relationship with
my wife she kept trying to get back
together and on the day of my wedding
she told me she still loved me and would
love no one else she said that this was
the last time she would bother me but
that she'll wait for however long it
took apparently she's honest in that
regard at least cuz my sister says she's
never been with anyone since so here's
what happened
recently my wife and I married for 7
years is now have two kids seven female
and three male my sister came over with
her own kids so the cousins could play
while my wife was out to pick up lunch
my sister sat me down and told me the
situation about my ex apparently she has
less than 6 months to live she refused
treatment and wants to live the last few
months to the fullest I guess that's why
her and my sister really went out of
their way to travel despite the pandemic
one thing on her bucket list though was
that she wanted to feel like my wife
again no sex no kissing she just wanted
me to be around the house she still
lives in the house we lived in again and
maybe hold her from time to time any
advice what should I
do I
mean
wow wow
look you've got a new life this woman
has nothing to offer you she didn't give
you children it sounds like she did
nothing but break your Tru TR and give
you a bunch of she's been harassing
you ever since you guys called off the
relationship why should you do anything
for her I'm sorry I I understand this
woman has numbered days and it might
sound a bit harsh
but why you don't owe this woman
anything you gave this woman your hand
in marriage and she betrayed that she
betrayed your trust she CH to ruin what
you guys had I think it's a shame that
he's even on Reddit asking for advice
about this I think maybe perhaps because
they were so young they were 10 when
they got together obviously there's
links there to his twin sister you know
maybe he feels like he has some kind of
connection to her if not emotionally at
least through Association I don't know
but if I was the now wife I would be
fuming I would be
very very
unhappy
and look it it's ultimately down to him
what he wants to do with this but I
think he needs to leave her behind
unfortunately it seems like and we see
this time and time again this woman has
made a bad decision and she can't accept
the fact that she's the one that's made
that bad decision she's trying to make
him the the the ex-husband she's trying
to make him the answer to her problems
you can see that she does hasn't learn
from her mistakes because even now she
quit her job and is now working in a
church pal discusses this a lot where
you see women often turn to religion
after things go really really wrong for
them and it's almost like they're
Outsourcing their guilt for their own
bad decisions and they're like oh well
God will forgive me or or Jesus will
forgive me or whatever that may look
like to
them I just think it's it's a bit Rich
that she thinks she can just come into
this man's life when they have children
as well fairly young children a
7-year-old and a 3-year-old and expect
this now father and new husband to play
husband with her just because
unfortunately and it is unfortunate she
has numbered
days that's not his responsibility he he
doesn't owe you anything and the fact
that she's even entitled enough to think
that this is even a reason reasonable
request just shows you the mentality of
this type of woman she's entitled she
thinks well I'm I'm dying so I can guilt
him into giving me what I want no I'm
sorry but no this is this is reality and
reality is Harsh just because you are
dying doesn't mean he owes you anything
and I know that sounds really nasty and
really horrible
but it's it's the truth that's what it
is no sex no kiss saying she just wanted
me to be around the
house and maybe hold her from time to
time there's always that extra little
Clause isn't there maybe hold her from
time to
time we know what she's really up to she
wants to get close so that you can maybe
hold her and then oh maybe you just
accidentally kiss and then oh maybe she
can die knowing that she split up what
you've now got so that she can remain
Victorious knowing that she was only
really the one for you no I see Sinister
narcissistic traits in this woman just
from this story I'm aware I'm reading
the story from one perspective and I
haven't got all of the facts but
look I think this is appalling I think
she should be very very ashamed of
herself and unfortunately she gets no
sympathy from
me just because of her current
situation the history is
there it's guilt tripping it's it's
narcissistic it's putting
herself on a pedestal and failing to
acknowledge her own mistakes in her life
and it's lack of accountability for her
own decisions that she's brought upon
herself and she's now trying to utilize
her current unfortunate situation as a
way to
manipulate a husband and a father into
turning his back on his family and
giving her the attention that she
craves don't do it dude don't give her
what she wants
she needs to learn her lesson however
that may be as harsh as it may
sound so yeah I mean I'm not
really I want to say I'm shocked I'm not
that
shocked she has numbered days hopefully
in her last days she can find some kind
of Peace in acknowledging that no one
else is responsible for her life other
than herself and there is great peace to
be found found in that awareness as hard
as it may be the initial realization
there is definitely peace to be found in
taking responsibility for your own life
because look if you're responsible for
your life you're you're essentially in
control of a lot of things whereas if
you blame the world for your problems
you blame everyone else for things then
that ultimately puts your life in their
hands and why would you want to do that
I don't know why don't you let me know
in the comments what you think of that I
hope you guys enjoyed today's episode
I'm sorry I'm not pal I did my best I'm
new to this bear with me yeah let us
know in the comments what you thought of
today's topics um if you have any other
kind of things that you perhaps want PE
to to look into leave a link in the
comments and obviously we'll try our
best to to take a look and see if we can
react to them or discuss them on the
show make sure you subscribe to the just
pearly things YouTube channel as I
mentioned pal is in the states so I'm
sure she'll be releasing some stuff from
over there so make sure you keep up to
date with that make sure you guys go
check out the audacity Network store the
link is in the description and you can
get your ultimate babe magnet the women
shouldn't vote t-shirt make sure you get
your women shouldn't vote t-shirts the
material is super soft and it is
guaranteed to get all of the ladies
looking in your direction even if you're
a girl it is guaranteed to get everyone
looking in your direction so if you're
feeling a bit invisible if you're
feeling like no one takes notice of you
get yourself a women shouldn't vote
t-shirt because I promise you will not
be feeling invisible after wearing that
so yeah go get your t-shirts and this
weekend me and our producer King it's
King's birthday by the way guys happy
birthday to our producer King we will be
covering the Logan Paul Dylan danis
fight and the KSI Tommy Fury fight I
know there's a lot of hype on all of
this so if you want to check out our
coverage then make sure you tune in to
the audacity Network to check out our
coverage of the Dylan danis Logan Paul
fight and the KSI Tommy Fury fight I am
very very excited I've never been to
Manchester before so yeah I'm excited to
check out the city get a feel for what
it's like up there and of course I am
very excited to see who is going to win
these fights I know there's been a lot
of tension in the buildup so yeah make
sure you tune in to the audacity Network
for that if you liked coverage here
today if you like some of the things I
had to say please do go show your
support to my channel my name is
Christine Grace Smith you can also find
my channel in the description below go
check out my series debunking The lunacy
make sure you head to playlist and click
on the series debunking The lunacy where
I take a deep dive into some of the
issues in today's society and try to
portray to you the side of things that
the mainstream media doesn't often
discuss so if that sounds like your cup
of tea well go check it out and I will
see you over there